FOX NEWS ALERT.
YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE AT THE
HEARING OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL NOMINEE,
WILLIAM BARR.
FIELDING QUESTIONS FROM
LAWMAKERS ON CAPITOL HILL, AND
IF ANYTHING MAJOR HAPPENS IN THE
HEARING, WE WILL TAKE YOU BACK
IN THEIR LIFE.
BARR SPENDING MOST OF THE DAY
ATTEMPTING TO REASSURE DEMOCRATS
THEY HAVE NO REASON TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND A PREVIOUS
MEMO HE WROTE ABOUT IT.
>> I BELIEVE IT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL BE ALLOWED TO COMPLETE
HIS INVESTIGATION.
I BELIEVE IT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF EVERYONE, THE
PRESIDENT, CONGRESS, AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT THIS
MATTER BE RESOLVED BY ALLOWING
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TO COMPLETE
HIS WORK.
I WROTE THE MEMO AS A FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO HAS OFTEN
WEIGHED IN ON LEGAL ISSUES OF
PUBLIC IMPORTANCE AND I
DISTRIBUTED BROADLY SO OTHER
LAWYERS WOULD HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF MY VIEWS.
MY MEMO WAS NARROW, EXPLAINING
MY THINKING ON A SPECIFIC
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE THEORY
UNDER A SINGLE STATUTE THAT I
THOUGHT, BASED ON MEDIA REPORTS,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL MIGHT BE
CONSIDERING.
>> Dana: DESPITE CLEARLY
LAYING OUT HIS STANCE, DEMOCRATS
TRIED TO HAMMER HIM ON THE SAME
ISSUE.
>> DOESN'T LOOK LIKE LIKE A JOB
APPLICATION?
>> THAT'S LUDICROUS.
IF I WANTED THE JOB AND WAS
GOING AFTER THE JOB, THERE ARE
MANY MORE DIRECT WAYS OF ME
BRINGING MYSELF TO THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTENTION THEN
WRITING IN THE 18 PAGE LEGAL
MEMORANDUM.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT YOU WILL NOT
ALLOW THE PRESIDENT OR HIS
ATTORNEYS TO EDIT OR CHANGE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL REPORT BEFORE IT
IS SUBMITTED TO CONGRESS OR THE
PUBLIC?
>> I'VE ALREADY SAID I WOULD NOT
PERMIT EDITING OF MY REPORT.
>> Dana: AS WE'VE SEEN IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS, DEMOCRATS
ALSO PRESSED THE NOMINEE ABOUT
WHETHER HE WOULD BE ABLE TO
STAND UP TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WHAT WOULD BE YOUR BREAKING
POINT?
WHEN WOULD YOU PICK UP AND
LEAVE?
WHEN IS YOUR JIM MATTIS MOMENT
WHEN THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED YOU
TO DO SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
IS INCONSISTENT WITH YOUR OATH?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
THAT I THINK IS WRONG AND I WILL
NOT BE BULLIED INTO DOING
ANYTHING I THINK IS WRONG BY
ANYBODY, WHETHER IT BE EDITORIAL
BOARDS OR CONGRESS OR THE
PRESIDENT.
I'M GOING TO DO WHAT I THINK
IT'S RIGHT.
>> Dana: I WANT TO PLAY THIS
OTHER SOUND THAT WAS CAUGHT OFF
CAMERA OF
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
>> SO YOU SEE THIS IS A PRETTY
EASY ROAD FOR HIM HEADING TO
CONFIRMATION?
>> I THINK SO.
WE'LL SEE.
>> Dana: I THINK SHE IS
READING THE TEA LEAVES.
LOOKS LIKE A CONFIRMATION THAT
MIGHT SAIL THROUGH.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
I GET ALL THE INTEREST IN THE
INVESTIGATION BUT IT'S AMAZING
HOW THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE FOLLOWING THE SAME SCRIPT.
SUPER OBSESSED WITH HOW THIS
WILL IMPACT MUELLER.
IF AN ASTEROID CAME AND WIPED
OUT HALF THE UNITED STATES, THE
MOST -- THE LEAD ON MSNBC AND
CNN WILL BE HOW DOES THIS IMPACT
THE MUELLER PROBE?
THERE ARE 150 MILLION PEOPLE
DEAD BUT WE NEED TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT THE MUELLER PROBE.
EVERY QUESTION IS HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO DO WITH DONALD TRUMP?
A BOILS DOWN TO THIS: WE HATE
DRUM.
YOU LIKE TRUMP?
WE HATE YOU TOO.
HE'S NOT APPLYING FOR EEG.
HE'S APPLYING TO GAIN ENTRANCE
INTO THE DONALD TRUMP HATE CLUB.
HE'S GOT TO SAY ALL THE RIGHT
THINGS.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A TREE HOUSE
OUT BACK WITH A SECRET KNOCK.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE A NOMINEE
WHO IS ALREADY BEEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEFORE AND WHEN
THE SENATORS WERE NOT REFERRING
TO HIM AS BARR, THEY WOULD SAY
GENERAL.
IT'S THE TITLE AND YOU HOLD IT
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
HE WAS ALMOST IN SEMIRETIREMENT.
WILLING TO BE A PUBLIC SERVANT.
HOW DO YOU THINK IT WENT?
>> Jesse: I THINK IT WENT
REALLY WELL AND JUAN WOULD AGREE
WITH ME.
I BELIEVE HE HANDLED THE
SENATORS DEFTLY.
IT WAS NOT A JEFF SESSIONS
SITUATION.
HE WAS VERY SMOOTH AND VERY
DIRECT.
EVERYTHING HE SAID WAS BASED ON
LAW.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHAT WOULD YOU
BASE A RECUSAL ON, HE SAID THE
FACTS.
IT STOPPED A FEW SENATORS IN
THEIR TRACKS.
THEY DON'T WANT A NUMBER AS AG.
THEY WANT A WEAK AG, SOMEONE
WHO'S GOING TO RECUSE AT THE
SLIGHTEST WHIFF OF CONTROVERSY
AND SOMEONE IS GOING TO TREAT
MUELLER LIKE A GOD.
I THINK HE STRADDLED IT WELL.
IF SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
I WILL DEAL WITH IT BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO ABDICATE MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS AG.
I'M GOING TO BE A STRONG
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE ALSO SAID IN THE MEMO THAT
COMEY DESERVED TO BE FIRED AND
MUELLER GOING AFTER AN
OBSTRUCTION CASE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT WAS ON WEAK LEGAL
GROUND AND MUELLER SHOULDN'T
HAVE STACKED HIS TEAM WITH
DEMOCRATS.
AND HE SAID, AND I THINK THIS
CAUGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTENTION, THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS TO GO AFTER HILLARY,
URANIUM ONE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, MORE THAN TO GO AFTER
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION IN 2016.
>> Dana: NOT URANIUM ONE AGAIN
AGAIN.
SPEAKING OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
MEETING WITH BILL BARR, HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT THAT.
LET'S PLAY IT AND WE WILL GET
JUAN TO REACT.
>> THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO KNOW.
HOW WELL DO YOU KNOW BOB MILLER.
I TOLD HIM BOB IS A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER AND SHOULD BE DEALT WITH
AS SUCH.
HE SAID SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT
LIKE SO ARE YOU ENVISIONING SOME
ROLE HERE?
I SAID ACTUALLY, MR. PRESIDENT,
RIGHT NOW I COULDN'T DO IT.
MY PERSONAL AND MY PROFESSIONAL
OBLIGATIONS ARE SUCH THAT I'M
UNABLE TO DO IT.
>> Dana: JUAN, IN ANOTHER
EXCHANGE, MR. BARR SAID HE DOES
NOT BELIEVE BOB MILLER WOULD
EVER BE INVOLVED IN A
WITCH HUNT.
DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS WILL BE
SATISFIED WITH HIS HEARING
TODAY?
>> Juan: NO.
TO ME, THIS IS ABOUT TRUMP WANTS
TO CONTROL THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I THINK THAT'S WHY HE FORCED OUT
JEFF SESSIONS, WHO WAS A TRUMP
LOYALIST BUT HAD RECUSED
HIMSELF.
I THINK THE STANDARDS, DANA, FOR
THE DEMOCRATS WAS IF THE ETHICS
OFFICIALS COME TO YOU AND SAY
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, WE THINK
YOU SHOULD RECUSE YOURSELF, WILL
YOU ABIDE BY THEIR FINDINGS?
HE SAID NO.
HE SAID HE WOULD GO WITH HIS OWN
SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT HE
SHOULD BE RECUSED.
SIMILARLY AND I THINK THIS IS
THE BIG POINT, IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF THE HATE ANYBODY CLUB.
THERE WAS A QUESTION OF WHETHER
OR NOT HE WILL RELEASE THE
MUELLER REPORT.
HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT, THE WAY
THAT WE DEAL WITH, I THINK THEY
ARE CALLED DECLINATION MEMOS
WHERE THEY DECLINED TO PROSECUTE
SOMEBODY, HE SAID WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THEM.
SO WE MAY NOT RELEASE ALL OF IT.
GUESS WHAT, THE POLLS ARE PRETTY
CLEAR ON THIS.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY HIS
NUMBER ONE JOB SHOULD BE RELEASE
WHATEVER MUELLER FINDS.
DON'T COVER IT UP.
DON'T LET GIULIANI EDIT IT.
PUT IT OUT THERE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND HE REFUSES
TO SAY IT.
>> Dana: THERE HAVE BEEN
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO SAID
THEY ALSO WANT THAT REPORT TO BE
PUBLIC.
IT WILL BE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DECISION.
>> Katie: IT'S BEEN A BIG
TOPIC OF CONVERSATION FOR THE
COUNTRY FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IT SHOULD BE RELEASED IN FULL AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE, BUT HE DIDN'T
SAY HE WASN'T RELEASING IT FOR
REASONS OF PERSONAL, POLITICAL
PURPOSES OR BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T WANT IT
RELEASE.
HE REFERRED BACK TO THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHEN IT COMES
TO RELEASING REPORTS LIKE THIS.
ONE THING I CAN'T TODAY I FOUND
INTERESTING IS I THINK THERE WAS
A BIT OF A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WAS SO
FOCUSED ON RUSSIA THAT ALL OF
THESE OTHER ISSUES KIND OF GOT
IGNORED.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE WERE
QUESTIONS TODAY ABOUT BILL
BARR'S ROLE AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN THE 1990s.
THERE'S A REASON WHY VIOLENT
CRIME AND MURDER IN AMERICA
TODAY HAS BEEN CUT IN HALF.
IT'S A RESULT OF A LOT OF THE
POLICIES THAT THEY PUT INTO
PLACE.
AS YOU HAVE CORY BOOKER AND
KAMALA HARRIS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUSHING FORWARD
WITH CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, HE
DID A GOOD JOB OF SAYING I'M NOT
GOING TO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
THINGS WE DID IN THE 1990s TO
BRING DOWN THE CRIME ACROSS
CITIES IN AMERICA.
AT THE SAME TIME, I'M OPEN TO
THE IDEA THAT MAYBE WE CAN PULL
BACK ON SOME OF THOSE POLICIES
NOW THAT WE'VE SOLVED A LOT OF
THE PROBLEM IN PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK AND WASHINGTON, D.C.,
CHICAGO CAME UP IN ONE PLACE
WHERE IT HASN'T BEEN SOLVED.
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S GOING TO
BE ONGOING FOR THE NEXT TEN, 20
YEARS.
>> Dana: HE ALSO SAID HE WOULD
NOT TARGET MARIJUANA.
THE LAWS AND MESS WITH WHAT THE
STATES ARE TRYING TO DO.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
>> Greg: I GUESS IT'S A GOOD
THING.
THAT WAS THE OTHER PROBLEM WITH
SESSIONS.
HE WASN'T GOING TO GO FOR IT.
THAT'S THE DIRECTION OF THE
COUNTRY.
I DO AGREE THAT WE HAVE TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT HOW GREAT THIS POLICE
REFORM IS GOING TO BE.
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS.
WE SAW DRAMATIC REDUCTION IN
CRIME, AND THAT HAD SOMETHING TO
DO WITH POLICIES THAT WE ARE NOW
KIND OF SAY MAYBE WE DON'T NEED
THEM ANYMORE.
THAT'S THE THING THAT ALWAYS
HAPPENS.
AFTER SOMETHING WORKS, WE ALL
STARTED THINKING MAYBE WE DON'T
NEED IT ANYMORE.
LIKE WALLS.
WE DON'T NEED ANY WALLS ANYMORE.
>> Jesse: HE WAS VERY STRONG
ON BORDER SECURITY.
HE SAID HE SUPPORTED BARRIERS
WHERE THEY WERE NECESSARY AND HE
WAS ALSO VERY AGAINST SANCTUARY
CITIES.
I THOUGHT EVERYBODY WATCHING
SHOULD BE PRETTY PLEASED WITH
THIS GUY.
>> Juan: I WILL SAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS PERSPECTIVE, HE IS NOT